hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up
climate activists say they will continue
to step up protests after just stop oil
disrupts the snooker World Championships
in Sheffield
the Lorry industry says plans to
decarbonize the sector are decades
behind Passenger cars
and we meet India's mangrove man who
single-handedly trying to help combat
Rising Coastal Waters
thank you
hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show where we track the changes to our
world and investigate some of the
potential solutions to The Climate
crisis climate activists have told Sky
News they intend to continue to disrupt
sporting events after two protesters
disrupted the world snooker
championships in Sheffield last night
just stop Euler demanding that the
government and all new approvals for oil
and gas exploration now our climate
change and energy correspondent Hannah
Thomas Peter is looking at the story
today she joins me now from Parliament
Square in central London Hannah what can
you tell us about this one
well this of course follows the
disruption of the world's snooker
championships late last night in which
two activists a man and a woman are
targeted with uh to to a pretty dramatic
effect those important games
um one of them threw orange powder and
the game had to be stopped another
attempted to glue herself to the table
uh both were arrested and of course on
Saturday there was the disruption by
another group animal rising of the Grand
National at Aintree and over a hundred
people were arrested in that situation
and these are examples of Splinter
groups well organized smaller groups
deciding to cause a maximum disruption
will the government do what they're
asking to to stop the expansion of of
new oil and gas sites in the North Sea
that's in just stop oil's case it's very
unlikely the government's in fact in the
middle of an expansion of oil and gas
drilling it says that we need fossil
fuels in the decades to come however
unpopular that might be but I did talk
to a just stop oil spokesman about the
logic behind these kinds of protests and
the public backlash and he revealed
really that the disruption and causing
anger is is the point
the disruption will continue until the
government make a meaningful statement
to Halt any new licensing I can sense
for any fossil fuel exploration in the
UK and we would encourage everyone who
understands how important this is to
join us on a slow March from 24th of
April in London
so Hannah that big event planned for
this weekend what do you know about it
well it's Earth week it's Earth Day on
the 22nd as such Extinction rebellion
and a number of other groups are joining
together that includes Greenpeace and
Friends of the earth and even the PCS
Civil Service Union to take part in a
series of events from Friday to Monday
and they're saying at least 30 000
people have already signed up they're
expecting many more they're calling it
one of the biggest climate protests the
UK has ever seen and the idea is to mass
around Parliament not necessarily to
disrupt things not necessarily to glue
themselves to things or get arrested
those are some of the tactics we've seen
before from Extinction rebellion in
particular but really to apply Mass
pressure to the government to do two
things to stop the extraction of new oil
and gas from the North Sea but also to
create emergency and civil assemblies to
give citizens a fairer say they say in
tackling climate change again very
unlikely the government's going to do
what is asked of it it is of course
pursuing an expansion of renewable and
clean energy and it is saying that it
can still decarbonize the power sector
still get to Net Zero by 2050 but in the
meantime it says fossil fuels in
diminishing amounts are a critical part
of the transition
okay Hannah thank you
and to let you know Tom Heap will
actually be presenting a special program
on the age of climate activism this
weekend that's on Saturday and Sunday at
3 P.M and 7 30 P.M
all right well let's have a look at what
else is making the headlines today and
the European Parliament has approved
sweeping reforms to the Block's climate
policies in a vote earlier today the
plans include an ambitious upgrade to
the eu's carbon Market which forces
polluters to pay for permits based on
the amount of carbon they emit the
European commission says it will lead to
a 62 drop in emissions by 2030 when
compared to levels of 2005. the CEO of
the rail company involved in a fiery
train crash in Ohio in February will
testify in front of the state's Senate
today the train was carrying hazardous
material when it came off the rails in
the village of East Palestine half of
the town's residents were evacuated and
have complained of ongoing health
problems following that crash now Ohio
has since passed stricter rail
regulations but it is unclear if they
can actually enforce them given that
they are superseded by federal law
and Hampton Court flower show is set to
Showcase a series of desert Gardens for
the first time that's in response to the
changing climate last year there were
such high temperatures during the show
that many flowers wilted or bloomed too
early rhs says with extremes in the
climate becoming more common in the UK
gardeners are looking to plant more
resilient species
the road haulage industry is warning
that efforts to decarbonize Britain's
lorries are decades behind Passenger
cars new analysis shows that there isn't
a single dedicated electric charging or
hydrogen refueling site for heavy Goods
vehicles on Britain's major road Network
the Society of motor manufacturers and
Traders says the lack of infrastructure
is putting a saving of up to 21 million
tons of carbon a year at risk well might
cause the chief executive of that
organization joins me now from
Birmingham Mike thank you so much for
talking to us today what needs to happen
for this sector to switch to Greener
Technologies
well some of the manufacturer's
perspective they're developing these new
vehicles electric vehicles hydrogen
Vehicles other Technologies and they're
there on the market available now but
it's all very well put them on the
market you have to have customers and so
the customer they have to have the
confidence to make that switch and the
biggest obstacle that they all cite is
the capacity of infrastructure if
they're to buy these vehicles you know
they'll be they'll be running up and
down the road most ways where will I be
able to charge
um is that there is it accessible
especially to heavy Goods Vehicles the
answer at the moment unfortunately is no
well Mike why can't the hgv drivers just
use the points that are there for
passenger cars
but I think you know we we consider what
is there for passing it's getting better
but there are still frustrations for Ev
drivers you've seen the headlines
especially over bank holiday weekends
massive cues and so forth but the fact
is that infrastructure is designed for
passenger cars but much smaller vehicle
much smaller footprints on the roads and
for many of these sites you wouldn't
physically be able to get in a big 44
ton you know tractor with a trailer
behind and they also need much higher
kilowatt power much stronger faster
charge because they have much bigger
batteries so they're just unsuitable
what you need is a dedicated system of
infrastructure one for passenger cars
once a commercial vehicles and
especially the heavy Goods Vehicles what
sort of range do they have Mike
I mean it varies I mean at the moment
some of the vehicles are around 200 to
300 miles summer games four or 500 miles
and that's going to increase
um clearly it is about developing the
technology making that technology more
affordable to increase the range
um with that sort of electrification
also when you think about hydrogen
um that gives you much greater range
potentially up to five six seven hundred
uh miles and you need that balance
because it's not a uniform industry that
heavy glass vehicle yes you have
Freights but you also have you know
refuse collection you also have you know
Refrigeration units cement makes a huge
variety some multiplicity of
Technologies is the most likely needed
for all those different solutions okay
Mike thank you so much for talking to us
my pleasure
right finally a man in India has been
reintroducing mangrove trees along the
shores of viping in the southern state
of Kerala to combat rising sea levels
he's known as mangrove mangro man he's a
retired fisherman and says he's seen the
impact of rising sea levels first hand
with families in his neighborhood forced
to relocate to Higher Ground
tidal flooding is a growing problem in
the area says the trees can help
mitigate that impact
mangroves are an important species
capable of creating a unique ecosystem
that's why I'm engaged in this effort to
plant and protect mangroves I'll
continue with this Mission until the day
that I die
right that's all from us today but I'll
be back at the same time tomorrow I'll
see you then
foreign